At long last we come to our last substantive lecture,
uh,
on,
on contract law.
So thanks for making it this far,
pat yourself.
On the back.
Today we're going to be discussing delegation assignment and third party
beneficiaries.
We've almost exclusively talk so far in this course about contracts formed are
not formed between two parties,
uh,
and performance or breach by those two parties.
Once a contract is formed,
to what extent may one of the parties delegate his or her duty to perform as a
promise or or assign his or her rights as a promise.
See under the contract to a third party without the consent of the other side of
the contract.
I find it helpful to remember the double d delegation concerns,
duties,
assignments,
concern,
contractual rights,
you delegate duties,
you assigned rights,
uh,
don't ever ask whether you can delegate a right.
You can only delegate duties.
So the restatement second of contracts provides the basic answer of how the law
regulates delegation.
And it's section three 18.
It says that unless otherwise agreed,
a promise requires performance by a particular person only to the extent that
the obligation has a substantial interest in having that person perform or
control the ax promise,
unless the obligation agrees otherwise.
Neither delegation or performance,
uh,
Nora contract assume the duty made with the Aba Gore by the person delegated
discharges any duty or liability of the delegating obligate [inaudible].
So what does that mean?
Under the restatement by default,
a promise or has the right to get delegate or duties except where the promise
see obligate [inaudible] has a substantial interest in having the original
promise or perform.
But unless otherwise the,
but this,
unless otherwise agreed,
proviso is important.
Parties in the initial contract can make any duty nondelegable or they can make
what might have been deemed a nondelegable duty because courts might deem the
promising you to have a substantial interest into a delegable duty by including
a clause saying that the duty is delegable.
So what's at stake here crucially is whether a promise or 10 delegate ex post
without the promises,
permission the promissory and promise.
He can always agree to modify the contract to allow the promise or to delegate a
duty to someone else,
even if the promise or has this substantial,
even if the promise see has a substantial interest in performance by the
original promise or,
and even if the contract,
the original contract included a non delegation provision.
So in what scenarios might someone have this kind of substantial interests such
that delegation of a contractual duty would be by default?
Impermissible.
The,
the typical scenarios involve contracts related to personal service or contracts
that involve a unique skill or discretion.
These contracts create duties that cannot be delegated unless the parties agree
in advance or,
uh,
ex post.
So if you,
for example,
in a highly recommended French language tutor agree that the tutor will give you
French lessons twice a week,
the tutor cannot delegate her duties to someone else.
Similarly,
the UCC section two to 10 provides a party may perform it his or her duty
through a delegate unless otherwise agreed or unless the other party has a
substantial interest in having the original promise or perform or control of the
ax required.
By the contract and no delegation of performance relieves the party delegating,
uh,
have any duty to perform or any liability for breach.
Because the UCC only cover sales of goods,
not the provision of personal services.
Exceptions to delegation under the UCC or less obvious,
although parties can of course specify in their contracts that delegation is not
permissible.
Note that both the restatement and the UCC keep the delegator on the hook for
breach of contract.
So even when they promise or has a right to delegate,
if the delegate t fails to perform the privacy can sue the original delegating
promissor on the basis of the original contract for breach
assignment is the analogous situation where after an initial contract is formed,
a promise see wants to assign her rights to the promissory is performance
without seeking the original promissory.
His permission.
Section three 17 of the restatement creates an analogous default rule saying
that contractual rights are assignable by default,
unless the assignment would materially change the duty of the obligation,
Gore or materially increased the burden or risk imposed on him by his contract
or materially impair his chance of obtaining return performance or materially
reducing its value to him.
Again,
him being the Ob Ob [inaudible].
If you promise to paint my house,
I probably cannot assign my right to your performance to someone who has a much
bigger house or a house that is far away that that's I my right of assignment
isn't the right to make your job of performance harder.
At least I can't do it by default unless I secure your permission at the time of
the initial contract or after the fact.
By modifying the contract delegation and assignment concern,
transfers of duties and rights to third parties after a contract is performed.
Now we turn to the question of ex ante assignment where the parties to the
initial contract agree that the promise or will perform for the benefit of third
party,
uh,
and give that third party the right to sue for any breach that occur.
This is a kind of ex ante assignment.
This ex ante assignee is called a third party beneficiary.
Sometimes this creation of a third party beneficiary is quite explicit and
intentional.
Imagine for instance that you signed a contract with an insurance company by
which terms the company will pay your daughter a substantial sum if you die.
Your daughter was not a party to the contract,
but she is a beneficiary of it,
a third party beneficiary.
In other cases,
third parties are beneficiaries of an agreement even when this wasn't the
contracting parties intention.
Suppose that Brian and Carolyn own adjoining plots of land and Brian contracts
with Alpha Company for Alpha to build a luxury building on Brian's land.
If the building is built,
Carolyn might very well benefit because her land values will increase
substantially by having a luxury building next door,
but she is not an intended benefit.
Officiary in what circumstances can a beneficiary who was not a party to a
contract assert claims based upon that contract?
Well,
the restatement of contracts differentiates between intended beneficiaries and
incidental beneficiaries.
Section three Oh two provides that unless otherwise agreed between promissory
and promise.
See,
a beneficiary of a of a promise is an intended beneficiary.
If recognition of a right to performance in the beneficiary is appropriate to
effectuate the intention of the parties and either the performance of the
promise will satisfy an obligation of the primacy to pay money to the
beneficiary,
or the circumstances indicate that the promise he intends to give the
beneficiary the benefit of the promised performance and incidental beneficiary
is the beneficiary who's not an intended beneficiary.
Section three or four then explains that a promise in a contract creates a duty
in the promise or to any intended beneficiary to perform the promise and the
intended beneficiary may enforce the duty.
So in our life insurance contract example,
the insurance company has a duty to pay your daughter the third party
beneficiary and your daughter as a third party beneficiary can enforce the
contract even though she wasn't an original party to it.
By contrast,
however,
section three 15 of the restatement explains that an incidental beneficiary
acquires by virtue of the promise,
no right against the promise or or the promise.
See Carolyn as your neighbor,
then we'd have no rights under the contract between uh,
uh,
be an Alpha company.
Of course,
the distinctions are not always easy to make and indeed typically require
examination on a case by case basis if the parties didn't explicitly designate,
uh,
the a daughter as a third party beneficiary when the initial contract does not
explicitly designate a third party beneficiary.
Courts typically look at a number of factors in determining whether the
beneficiaries are intended or incidental.
The language of the promise which the,
uh,
third party seeks to enforce is one of the factors,
the intention or purpose of the parties or the primacy to be derived from the
evidence.
In addition to the promise,
some vague notion of utility.
That is why,
why not enforce the promise if the parties so intended in the promise,
he is not bringing suit and some even less explicit notions about the needs of
the commercial setting in which the promise was made.
Interestingly,
the third party beneficiary need not show reliance upon the promise,
uh,
to gain protected status.
The primary source,
then a third party beneficiary rights is agreement of the promise or and
promise.
See and enforcement turns on a judgment that the purpose of these parties will
or will not be effectuated.
So let's consider how courts have dealt with the question of whether a
beneficiary was in an intended bender in it was an intended beneficiary and some
real cases.
We can see an entertaining example in Warren versus Monaghan beach beaches,
jewelry company.
The plaintiff,
uh,
was,
Warren's fiance a,
the plaintiff gave her what he thought was a diamond ring,
which he had purchased from the defendant's store before purchasing the ring.
The fiance had spoken to the employees of the company about the size,
type and style of ring he wanted for Warren.
And the company suggested that Warren might like or dislike about the ring.
It turned out that the ring though contained no diamond,
just glass and cubic Zirconia.
Uh,
and so the question was Warren and intended beneficiary of the contract between
the jewelry company in warrants fiance.
Well,
a Florida court determine quote,
the contract dealings between Anderson and the appellee and the subsequent
dealings between appellant and appellee clearly establish appellant as an
intended third party beneficiary of,
of the contract at issue.
Now consider a case with perhaps greater public interest implication Zig Goss
versus superior court.
Their tenets of the San Francisco apartment building that was financed with a
federally insured mortgage pursuant to the National Housing Act and regulations
promulgated pursuant to that act,
the financing agreement between the landlord and the Department of Housing and
Urban Development,
Hud required that the landlord's not charge more than Hud's approved rent
schedule.
But the plaintiffs allege that the landlords were charging in excess of that
schedule where the tenants,
uh,
intended beneficiaries of the financing agreement.
And the court said,
yes,
quote,
even the most cursory review of the statutes and regulations which resulted in
the contract and the present case leads to the conclusion that the tenants
constitute the class which congress intended to benefit unquote.
This has been just a very quick run through of delegation assignment and third
party beneficiary law.
There's much more we could discuss but to recap,
uh,
here's what we've learned.
Number one,
we've discussed delegation and learned that generally parties may delegate
contractual duties and less a party has a substantial interest in the particular
party performing the contract.
We also discuss cases that typically a fall within this substantial interest
exception including contracts for service or those involving a unique skill.
We also discussed assignment which is a very analogous regulating whether you
can assign your rights under a contract and by default you can,
unless that assignment isn't going to impose extra duties,
burdens on the promise or we talked about third party beneficiary law and the
difference between intended beneficiaries and incidental beneficiaries.
The former can enforce contractual terms.
The ladder may not to test our knowledge of this distinction.
We ran through a couple of the cases,
and in all three of these contexts,
delegation,
assignment,
and third party beneficiary law,
you should be clear on the default nature of these,
uh,
legal rules that the parties in their initial agreement can explicitly designate
people to be.
Third Party beneficiaries are not to be third party beneficiaries.
They can explicitly allow delegation of duties or not allow it.
They can explicitly allow assignment or not allow it.
And that the crucial area of the law here is establishing default rules in the
absence of such agreements.